Hey, Vsauce. Michael here. And today we are going to talk about time, specifically, how
much time we have. What's the oldest a person
can ever be? Well, the world record for the
world's longest living person belongs to Jeanne
Calment, a French woman who lived to be 122.
Right now, at this very moment, there are
only 37 people alive who were born in the
1800's. Those 37 people have lived in three
different centuries. But, as medical knowledge
expands and our understanding of biology improves,
people are living longer, and longer. In fact,
scientists believe that, based on statistics,
the first person who will ever live to be
150 has already been born. It could be one
of you. But, according to the math, it's probably
someone who was born last year.
Here's the thing. As humans get older, the
likelihood of them dying increases, but there
are some types of animals that have what is
called Negligible Senescence, also known as
biological immortality, and these types of
animals have never been observed to actually
age. Animals, like the Hydra, can only die
because of accidents, disease, or predators.
The world's oldest living individual tree
has clocked in at more than 4,600 years old.
It's called the Methuselah Tree and it exists
somewhere in this forest. Government officials
won't actually release its exact location
to protect it from vandalism, but it's out
there.
The lifespan of an organism can be even longer
than that if you include clonal colonies.
For instance, these Quaking Pines all look
like individual trees, but they're actually
all clones of one genetic code. They all share
a root system, and the root system continues
to make more trees, meaning that these trees
are all part of the same organism, and experts
have calculated, based on the roots system,
that this one, male Quaking Pine has been
around for at least 80,000 years.
But let's get back to humans, and rather
than talking about how time is, let's talk about
how time feels. Intense moments of your life
are remembered as lasting much longer than
times that were relatively dull. Psychologists
say that the reason for this is that our brains
take deeper and richer memories of events
that are novel, or events that are intense,
than ones that aren't.
When your experiences are intense and novel,
you're not remembering more things about it,
but you are making more copies. Rather than
just making normal memories, during stress
the amygdala gets involved and also remembers
things, and many people believe that is why
intense moments are remembered as lasting longer.
This phenomenon becomes quite mind-blowing
on a macro-scale. Think of it this way: when
you are a one-year-old baby, one year represents
100 percent of your life, but when your turn
two years old, that second year was only half
your life, and the next year you live through
is only a third of your life, and by the time
you turn 80, one year only represents an 80th
of your life. Those percentages are important
because they may explain why your childhood
feels like it took so long, but as you get
older, the years seem to fly by.
You have more novel experiences when you're
young. You first learn a language, you first
see your mother, you first learn to walk,
you have your first kiss. These are all deeply
and richly remembered by your brain, and so,
later on, it feels as if they took longer
to happen.
Now, here's what's really mind-blowing. Let's
look at a graphical representation of the
percentage of your life that each successive
year is. The first year is 100 percent, the
second year is only half, the third year is
a third, and so-on will go all-the-way out to
80. Now, using this representation, under
this model, when you turn 80 years old and
look back at your life, the point that feels
like the middle isn't your 40's, it's your
early 20's.
The good news here is that the more novel things
you do, and things you see, and places you
visit, and people you meet, the slower time
feels, and the more rich it feels. So, go
out there and do something cool, do something
weird, do something new. Subscribe to Vsauce
if you haven't already!
And as always,
thanks for watching.